ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by mr. James Kalia how are you
today hello yeah good to talk to you I'm
doing well welcome to the show um a lot
of the listeners will have heard us talk
at length about how much we loved atomic
habits it's been a an absolute game
changer first this year and I'll thank
you so much I'm glad you enjoyed it
yeah it's it really is a big paradigm
shift for a lot of the things that we've
been reading recently it wasn't they say
that the best books are ones that tell
you things that you already know and a
lot of the things in atomic habits it
pieced together in a way that I hadn't
ever seen before
a lot of the ancillary little bits and
pieces and then compiled them into just
stop being an idiot this is what you
need so I'm super excited to go through
it today
great yeah I'm excited to talk about it
- brilliant so first and foremost why do
we need to be bothered about habits yeah
it's a good question you know I mean I'm
one hands like everybody has habits
right we're all building them all the
time whether you're thinking about it or
not so that part I think is provides a
little bit of a reason why if you're
building habits anyway then it kind of
makes sense to understand what they are
and how they work so that you can maybe
build them in a way that benefits you
rather than in a way that hinders you
and I think that is a deeper truth about
habits that they're kind of like a
double-edged sword you know like they
can either build you up or tear you down
and you need to understand the kind of
fundamental pieces of them and how to
adjust them so you can make sure they're
working for you which kind of naturally
leads to a question like what is a habit
and why do we bother for me at all and I
think like a simple way to describe it
is that habits allow you to solve the
problems of life with less energy and
effort than you would otherwise need and
you know what all life requires energy
to exist if you if you don't have energy
then you don't survive and so energy is
very precious for that reason and your
brain is looking for ways to consume
whenever possible you know this makes
just logical sense right like if you
imagine like our ancestors living on the
savanna if you could forage for berries
and a patch that's a hundred meters away
then why would you bother foraging for
berries and a patch that's like ten
thousand meters away or on the other
side of the mountain or whatever right
like you're gonna seek the path of least
resistance to get the results that you
want and habits are sort of a shortcut a
mental shortcut that your brain uses to
do that kind of thing on a daily basis
so take for example the habit of tying
your shoe the first time you do it you
don't know how to tie your shoe and you
have to think carefully about how to
make the knot since someone has to teach
you how to do it and so on but after you
do it a hundred times or a thousand
times or ten thousand times pretty soon
you can tie your shoes while you're
talking to somebody you're thinking
about your to-do list for the day you
just paid you pretty much can do it on
autopilot and so in a small sense tying
your shoe is like a problem that you
face on a daily basis and your brain has
automated the solution and habits allow
you to do that in all different areas of
life all the time
do you automate the solutions to the
recurring problems in life which means
you can focus on other things and direct
your attention elsewhere so for that
reason habits are like so central to our
experience that we often overlook them
like you don't even really think about
brushing your teeth or tying your shoes
or unplugging the toaster after each use
or all these other things that you do
each day but your habits are the thing
that help you function and operate in
the world in a more efficient manner
then there's also like the deeper or
bigger impact that habits have which if
you think about like the results that
you want in life most of your results
are like a lagging measure of the habits
that precede them so you know your bank
account is a lagging measure of your
financial habits or your weight as a
lagging measure of your eating habits or
your knowledge is a lagging measure of
your learning habits and so by a lot of
the time people think what they need is
a different outcome they think they need
a bigger bank account or a lower number
on the scale or you know more
intelligence and wisdom but actually
what they need are the habits that
perceive those things and so I think
that's another
why habits are really important and why
to focus on them which is that habits
are the leading indicator of all the
lagging results that we really want and
aspire to achieve in life I totally get
it can you talk about systems versus
goals please it was sure it was
something that I'd seen in chasing
excellence by Ben Bergeron and a couple
of other books and hadn't really put it
together but it was incredibly
succinctly and brutally delivered
delivered to remind me just how many
mistakes are sometimes make in atomic
habits yeah Thanks well I mean you know
I think this is a these are pitfalls
that we all fall into humans are tend to
be very goal-oriented and you know
sometimes that makes sense right for
like our survival you need essentially
like the goal of finding food and water
in order to motivate yourself to
actually go get that and and to survive
but in modern society and just in daily
life we often kind of take that to the
extreme so before I criticize or point
out the flaws and goals I should say
like I think goals are useful you know
so it's not that they don't serve a
purpose or entirely useless like one of
the things that having goals does is it
provides clarity it you know shows you
what direction to focus on or where to
direct your attention goals can also act
as like a filtering mechanism so it's
much easier to say no to something when
you know what your goal or your purpose
is right otherwise like different
opportunities come your way during life
and you're like yeah okay I'll try that
but if you know what your goal is and
that opportunity doesn't relate to that
then you can much more easily say no so
those are some of the things that goals
do well but there's a lot of things that
goals don't do well or that we kind of
over value the importance of goals for
making progress and so one of the things
is that and I've actually talked to Ben
Bergeron about this before one of the
things is that winners and losers often
have the same goals so in any particular
domain you know like in the Olympics
pretty much every Olympian has the goal
of winning the gold medal it's not the
goal that separates them or in if you're
applying for a job pretty much every
candidate who applies for a job as the
of getting that job so the goal is not
the thing that makes the difference and
so the question is well what is it and
it's the process and the habits and the
preparation that precede the goal or in
some cases follow after you've set your
sights on something and so that
collection of habits and processes the
collection of habits that you follow and
use to prepare that's what I call your
system and so I think that we should
place more value on the system and less
value on the goal and there are a couple
other reasons or why this this
distinction between the two are
important so like let's just lay out
kind of in clear examples what's the
difference between a system and a goal
so your goal if you're a basketball
coach your goal might be to win the
championship but your system is the way
that you recruit players and assistant
coaches the drills that you do at
practice each day your process for
reviewing film and you know if you're a
fair writer your goal might be to write
a best-selling book but your system is
how you research topics you know your
writing habit and how you show up and
write each day the editorial process and
how you review your writing and improve
it and on and on right so the the goal
is the outcome that you want the system
is the process that you follow for
getting there and goals can be helpful
for clarity but systems are good for
actually making progress and so when you
want to actually move forward you need
to shift your attention you kind of need
to like metaphorically put the goal on
the shelf and then pour all of your
energy into building a better system
the other interesting thing is if you
think about this in a long-term
standpoint so true long-term thinking is
really goalless thinking because if you
achieve a goal it only changes your life
for the moment right like you could set
a goal to like let's say your bedroom is
messy and you set a goal to clean your
room well you could get motivated for a
few hours and clean your room and you do
have a clean room for now but if you
don't change the sloppy messy habits
that led to a dirty room in the first
place then you just turn around you know
a week later or a month later and you
end up with a dirty room again
yeah and so
it's actually you think you need a clean
room but actually what you need are the
habits that precede a clean room are the
habits that deliver a clean room and
this I think is true in so many areas of
life we think that we need to change our
goals but actually we need to change our
system actually we need to change the
habits that we're following each day and
so this is why I say you don't rise to
the level of your goals you fall to the
level of your systems you can have
whatever goal you want every candidate
has the goal to get the job every
Olympian has the gold win the gold medal
but if you don't have the systems to
support that if you don't have the
habits and rituals to actually make it a
reality
then your goals are gonna fall flat and
so having the vision is one thing but
it's probably the easier thing it's
actually the habits that that make you
move forward and make progress
one of our friends George recently sent
a message saying that he has a project
that he's going to begin working on and
he was really excited about it but he
knows that he gives himself a degree of
dopamine kick just by talking about the
goal know that verbalizing of the goal
and the communicating of it is almost
like a masturbatory kind of action that
gives him this sense of I will have
achieved something whilst also having
actually achieved nothing and I think
that's a very delicate balance that you
need to strike yeah it's interesting you
know sometimes when people talk about
projects that they want to achieve it
creates like a form of accountability
for them and so like telling somebody
about it they feel like oh I don't want
to fall flat on you know telling this
promise that I made and so they find it
more motivating but I've often
experienced what George is mentioning
where you tell somebody about something
and you feel like you did something
about it because you're talking about it
you know like this is the kind of thing
where you you have like a business idea
so you work on it on the weekends you
tell people oh yeah I'm like think about
starting this thing but you never
actually go anywhere it's just like
talking about it or debating like which
of the company be named or which of our
business cards look like or which of the
logo be it provides the illusion of
making progress and that it reminds me
of this quote I just just saw this quote
for the first time the other day from
Bob Knight the famous basketball code
where he said like the will to win is
not what you need like having the will
to win is easy everybody wants to win
what you need is the will to prepare to
win and I think that is kind of like it
distinguishes a little bit the
difference here like yeah everybody
wants to have a successful business or
start some cool project or like do
something interesting but are you
actually fascinated with all the aspects
of preparing for that right like are you
it's not writing a book that is like
everybody's like yeah be cool to have a
best-selling book but the book is the
easy part like the the harder part the
thing that you really need to be
fascinated with is do you love
researching stories do you like editing
your own writing do you like sitting
down and writing for you know 20 minutes
every morning or whatever and it's the
people who and this is this is kind of a
strange thing about a lot of areas of
life which is the people who get the
best results in a particular area are
actually often not the people who are
doing it for the results as the people
who love the process of doing the thing
like the people who read about early
retirement and the best investing
strategies and figuring out how to
optimize their money they don't actually
need the financial advice a lot of the
time they already have their act
together financially but the reason they
have their act together is because they
love the process of reading about that
stuff and implementing it utilizing
those ideas and so often the people who
need the advice are not the ones who
love digging for it and the ones who
love digging for it don't even really
need it anymore but that's the very
reason why they don't need it is because
they love the process of it yeah I
suppose that that highlights a big
difference between people that do things
for passion and do things to get a grind
to complete it something is a task that
needs to be fulfilled members run again
in chasing excellence touches on this a
lot where he says that the people who
love the process will always beat the
people who have to force themselves and
use willpower to get up and do it
because the people who feel like this is
their life and who don't have to reach
into that willpower pot to go and do
something that it just comes naturally
to them the same as breathing think
catcher and David sorted got asked about
how do you train seven hours a day and
sleep all the time and do all of this
sort of stuff and
said well if you gave me any life in the
world this exactly what I am doing right
now on what you think is hard is exactly
what I would choose to do no much easier
is it going to be for katrin
davidsdottir to train seven hours a day
then for someone who hates the gym like
it's infinitely more easy yeah I think
you used an example about a basketball
coach as well who who said something
similar to do with it's not the players
who have the most skill but the ones who
get bored the least with training yeah
yeah I was a weightlifting coach that I
had met and some of my training where he
said I asked him like well you know
what's the difference between the people
at the top of the field and the people
who just kind of have talent but fizzle
out and he was like well you know
certainly like talent and genes and
nutrition and all that plays into it but
at the end of the day it just comes down
to who can handle the boredom of doing
the same lifts over and over again every
day and I think that's true in so many
areas of life for many people it feels
boring but for occasionally they find
out if someone finds a way to love the
boredom to fall in love with it to make
it the thing that's enjoyable to them
and I think I think the way that I would
just building off of your example of
Katrin and kind of like how she loves
the process loves the fact of years from
a lot of top athletes like it's actually
not an obligation to them to live the
light to train the way that they're
training it's it feels like what they
want to do and in fact this is exactly
the opposite of what you hear from many
athletes when they retire they
specifically say that they retire
because it starts to feel like an
obligation because it no longer feels
fun so I think that you know the world
this is how I would break this down so
it's not the talent doesn't matter and
it's only about passion and motivation
and trying hard both nature and nurture
matter both talent and effort make a
difference but in a world of seven
billion people you can pick any domain
you want and you're gonna find somebody
who is willing to sacrifice everything
for that particular area for that
particular domain you're gonna find
somebody who is both talented
and it doesn't feel like an obligation
to them it just feels great and they
were married a very dangerous individual
yes right like that's good luck
competing with somebody like that if you
feel like you need willpower to make it
work because they're both even if you're
talented
there's talented as you are and it feels
like fun and so that's like a really
hard combination to strike I am I always
think of Steffi Graf the famous tennis
player so she when she was a kid in
Germany they she was part of this study
just randomly she avenue part of the
study of young german tennis players and
they measured i think she was maybe 12
to 14 somewhere in that range and they
measured all kinds of things they
measured like you know their physical
characteristics aerobic capacity
strength explosiveness and she tested
highest on all those scores but then
they also measured the psychological
traits and she tested highest on
competitive desire it was like well it
literally doesn't matter if you're as
talented at her because she wants it
more and it doesn't matter if you wanted
as much as her she's better than you so
that combination is just like a parabola
and I think that the world is becoming
it's developing infinitely more niches
than it ever did before this is what the
Internet is enabling right there are
more and more little pockets for people
to find the thing that's just right for
them and so what's hopeful in my mind is
that almost anybody can try to find
something like that for themselves
something that they are naturally suited
to do that they tend to be very good at
and that they that feels like fun to
them that doesn't that doesn't feel like
an obligation and so what you're really
looking to do is you're looking to align
your ambition with your ability and if
you have both of those things working
for you then you can really make some
progress so I feel like that's something
that you know Katrin happens to for her
it happens to be CrossFit for other
famous you know Steffi Graf or whatever
like we see there's some of these very
visible examples in sports but there are
probably a lot of other examples of
people we never have heard their names
but they found their thing too and so
you just need to try to figure out
where's that niche where my ambition is
aligned with my ability because I think
at the top of pretty much any domain you
find people that are not only
well suited and talented but also well
trained and so you you kind of have both
where you you match up your effort and
your and your of the natural ability for
anyone who's listening who thinks I
haven't quite found whatever my natural
calling may be or whatever feels fun to
me
are there any mechanisms or any bits of
advice that you could give to them yeah
so you know I mean this is hard right
like I in a lot of ways I feel like I'm
still searching for it I've had seasons
in my life where I feel like I found it
but then nothing long-term that's like
really stuck so I talk about this a
little bit later in the book this whole
idea of what's called the Explorer
exploit trade-off and so explore exploit
trade-off basically says early on and it
depends on what timeline you're looking
at you could say for example I have 30
years to work so early on in my career's
maybe the first 5 years or something or
you could say we have this project that
we're working on and the deadline is six
months away so early on is the first two
to three weeks but early on what you
should do is you should explore widely
you should look for as many options as
possible to solve the problems that
you're facing so maybe you look for a
bunch of options for getting this
project done or new pieces of software
you could use or different strategies
that you could follow for implementing
the ideas that you want to execute on in
the project for your career sometimes we
call this internships or like exploring
a couple different fields doing some
kind of rotational management program
maybe it's trying like three or four
different careers over the first five
years but you want to explore widely
then as time starts to get tighter and
you get closer and closer to the
deadline the project or you get deeper
and deeper into your career you've
already explored a lot and so we want to
do is start exploiting the best option
that you found so far so that you can
get some results you know like you're
getting deeper in your career explore
the best thing you exploit the best
thing you found so you can make some
money and start saving for retirement
and accumulating wealth or you're
getting closer to the project deadline
so let's use the best idea that we found
so we can get some results and get this
thing finished it's like a split and
split test in marketing yeah it is like
split testing it's like split testing
and then yeah
doubling down on the winners as you
start to find them right but similar to
split testing where you know like Google
or Facebook or whatever they've got
there they figured out a lot of winners
at this point but they aren't they have
they remember quick split testing
entirely they still run some tests maybe
10% of the audience and 90% of the time
they do the thing that they know is best
already and explore exploit is asking
you to do the same thing in your life so
you continue your career and you're
focused most of the time 80 to 90
percent on the thing that's the best
solution you've found so far
but you still spend 10 to 20% of your
time toiling with side projects or
reading about a different career or
seeing if you can come across something
else that lights you up even better and
so that's one strategy for trying to
find that that niche that area that is
best for you but the other thing you can
do I don't think I don't think most
people perhaps it you know I I kind of
know it's true but even I don't even
know if I have capitalized on it enough
the Internet has opened up way more
things than you could ever imagine that
could be a job now you don't most things
that people talk about being jobs like
there are all kinds of stuff that's a
that's a job that doesn't seem like it
could be like they're you know there's a
very popular website called Pro Football
Focus subscription product it analyzes
all the stats in the NFL and then ranks
and grades players by position well that
to whoever the guys were that started
that that was just some like nerd side
project that they loved cuz they were
really into football and wanted to
calculate stats and like rank the
players and stuff right and now that's
their full-time job it's the successful
business
same thing with you know there are a
bunch of things on basketball and other
sports Ben Thompson's subscription
newsletter and blogs for tech curry is a
good example of this he just loved
writing about technology and how it was
changing businesses and so he started
blogging about it and then he started
charging a newsletter that was like 10
bucks a month or 100 bucks a year and
now he's got tons of subscribers and a
really successful website just blogging
about how technology impacts Amazon or
Google or Facebook or whatever and
that's like kind of a new form of like
tech
journalism but even like different and
in some way where he can do long form or
he can just focus on the companies he
cares about or write about whatever he
wants and you know those are some
examples that are like more data-driven
and in writing based but it's true for
all kinds of sucks all kinds of stuff I
came across a woman the other day who
has a company that all she does is make
yarn and sells yarn and she just had you
know she's got a bunch of employees she
just had her first $10,000 day like I
mean there's is a huge business and my
point is that there are like an infinite
range of niches like that available on
the internet and so digging around and
looking for that and thinking like what
comes easily to me already what is
enjoyable to me already and then trying
to find a way that you can make money
from that if you're passionate enough
about it now you can probably find
enough people to make a job out of it
and even if you can't make enough money
out of it it's gonna feel so much fun
it's gonna feel like so much fun that
you don't even really care so we did and
for the listeners at home they may be
able to do this little thought
experiment for themselves but we're
going to run through it in an upcoming
episode a little bit more thoroughly but
here's a brief overview if you were to
take the wage your take-home wage from a
typical job which is something that you
don't necessarily love and I was to say
to you you can give back some of your
wage in return for an allowance to do
with your job so let's say you are
allowed to wear whatever you want so you
can come into work in wearing pajamas
okay there you go there's I'll give you
1,500 1,500 quid back you know right
okay now you can work from home you
never need to go in the office in that
[ __ ] hell right okay well you can
have we could have 2,000 like pounds
back to that and that right now you can
choose your own working hours and you
like oh my god another 2,000 pounds back
and we sat around a dinner table and we
managed to get it to the point where the
guy that we were running this experiment
on was paying us to come to work away
all of it and we were like look man like
the AIDS evident that you hate your job
so much you're so unfulfilled with this
that you would literally pay to not have
to go and do it and then
just to to bookend this this particular
part in terms of finding purpose and
things that you really enjoy in life
Gretchen Rubin used this really cool
example about what did you do between
the ages of 8 and 14 what was it that
you spent your time doing around about
then and she uses this example of one of
the best color pickers in the world -
this woman who matches up very unique
different shades it's for interior
design and she does stuff for clothing
companies and branding companies and
marking and all these sort of things
someone once asked her like so what what
qualifications have you got says what I
really I don't have anything I kind of
learned on the job but when I was 9
years old I had the biggest Crayola set
that was available and I spent all of my
time just playing around with colors and
similar to myself between the age of
like 6 and 14 I loved listening to
audiobooks I just used to pound
audiobooks like 20 cassette audiobooks
and listen to that and what is the
podcast platform if it's not the
modern-day version of an audiobook right
so you know as a bit of a canary in the
coalmine
that might be a good place for for some
people to start I think moving forward
I'm so yeah those are good examples
thank you we've talked about the kind of
big picture stuff now let's let's get
into the nitty-gritty the the murky
world of actually how habits are set and
and and how that comes could you take us
through it
so I divide a habit into four different
stages and so just from a high-level
those stages are cue craving response
and reward so the cue is something that
gets your attention like you see a plate
of cookies on the counter that's a
visual cue or the ambulance comes behind
you on the street and you hear it and so
you pull to the side of the road like
that's an auditory cue or your phone
buzzes in your pocket that's like a
physical or a tactile cue and so it can
be any of the senses but usually it
tends to be visual humans are very
visual creatures so that that tends to
be the most predominant sense but the
cue gets your attention the second step
is the craving which is dependent on how
you interpret the cue so it you whether
you get a craving or the motivation to
act whether you predict that it would be
useful to take a response
is on the meaning that you assigned to
the queue so if you have two people who
walk into a living room and they see a
pack of cigarettes sitting on the table
the first person might they've been a
smoker for ten years and they see it and
may get this craving of oh I want to
pick a cigarette up in smoke
so they interpret that visual cue is
favorable the second person has never
smoked today in their life and so they
see the cigarettes and they just think
oh it's just a pack of cigarettes and
they move on and so it's really about
the meaning that you assigned to that
visual cue that determines whether you
act on it or not then there's the
response and finally there the response
is the actual habit or action itself and
then finally there's the reward or the
outcome so visual cue you see a plate of
cookies on the counter craving you
interpret them as favorable you predict
Oh that'll be sweet sugary tasty so you
responds grab one take a bite and then
finally the reward and the reward serves
two purposes the first is it satisfies
the craving that came before the action
so you predicted that the tape of the
cookie would be tasty and sweet and once
you take a bite it is in fact sugary
tasty sweet so that resolves that
craving and then the second thing that
it does is it teaches your brain what to
repeat for next time because when
actions are followed by a feeling of
pleasure when it's enjoyable or you got
you solve the problem you were facing or
you had some kind of successful feeling
at the end of the habit it feels good
and your brains like hey that was
enjoyable I should do this again next
time when I'm in a similar circumstance
and so it's actually closing the
feedback loop and training your brain
what to do again and again and once
you've done something enough times and
gotten the outcome that you hoped from
it again and again and again the
feedback loop gets really tight and you
can do it pretty much on autopilot you
don't even really think about it you're
just sort of automatically whenever you
put a shoe on and see a shoe untied on
your foot that's the cue and you know oh
I just go ahead and tie the shoe and
that's how I get this reward that I'm
looking for and having a shoe securely
on my foot and so on the the example
that I give to kind of wrap all this
together and show you how common it is
for your brain to do this and how
quickly we proceed through all those
stages without thinking
is the process of flipping out a light
switch so when you first move into a new
home or an apartment you don't even
think you don't know where all the
switches are or what switch turns on
which light right like you're you're
kind of I need to figure out okay it's
not exactly that one whatever and then
over time after a few days you start to
learn okay this is the light that's in
the kitchen you know I flip this switch
and pretty soon you walk into a room
it's dark so cue the room is dark
craving I want to be able to see
response I reach exactly for the right
switch and flip it on reward I'm now
able to see and of course you never
think about those four stages and you're
doing it happens in a fraction of a
second but all four are being completed
right away and so that's an example of
what it looks like once the habits
formed and you're doing it pretty much
on autopilot yeah I totally get that I
think you could probably place me
anywhere in my bedroom in total
blackness and I'd be able to find the
light switch it's one of those very
bizarre like homing homing signal things
that so I wanted to talk about making
good habits and breaking bad habits
because the process is similar but also
completely opposite for both of them
right could you take us through making
good habits so someone may want to begin
the process for writing a book or they
may want to spend more time outside or
they might want to do get into an
exercise routine or whatever it might be
how do you make a good habit so once you
understand those four stages you kind of
have four different points of
intervention for building a habit or
breaking a bad one and so I call these
the four laws of behavior change but the
the basic way to think about it is for
the cue the first law behavior change is
to make it obvious you want the cues of
your good habits to be obvious available
visible easy to see the easier they are
at a spot and get your attention the
more likely you are to act on them
the second law behavior change is
related to the craving so you want to
make your habits attractive more
attractive or appealing a habit is the
more likely you are to feel motivated to
do it for the third law behavior change
the response make it easy and the easier
more convenient frictionless habits are
the more likely
that are to occur and easier they're
gonna be to perform and then finally the
fourth law behavior changes to make it
satisfying and that's related to the
reward or the ending of the habit you
want the ending to be satisfying
enjoyable pleasurable because it will
give you a reason to repeat it again in
the future
so those four laws make it obvious make
it attractive make it easy make it
satisfying they give you kind of like a
simple easy-to-understand framework for
how to adjust a habit to make a good
habit stick and you know of course I go
over all kinds of methods in the book
for doing each one of those and we can
talk about some of them here if you'd
like and then for breaking a bad habit
you just invert those four laws so
rather than making the cues obvious you
want to make the cues of your bad habits
invisible rather than making it
attractive make it unattractive make it
difficult
make it unsatisfying and so by having
those four kind of guiding principles
now you can start to look around your
habits investigate them and try to
figure out how can I do that how can I
make the cues invisible or how can I
make it more difficult to perform or how
can I add a consequence so it's
unsatisfying to do this habit and so on
and basically I like those four laws
because they kind of give you a simple
line of questioning that you can use for
inspecting your own habits and trying to
figure out where exactly should I try to
apply the pressure or make a change I
think certainly when before reading
atomic habits and again like I say
individually a lot of this stuff had
already appeared in my consciousness
through one form or another but until
there is that framework it's so nebulous
and kind of just cloudy and and
difficult to grasp that without the
step-by-step process that you're going
through it's a habit for building habits
in a way or a framework that you can
wrap building habits around I suppose
well I think a lot of people have had
this experience where you make a change
or two but it kind of it almost feels
like you're just making random changes
and they never amount to anything and so
my and this comes back to what we talked
about earlier about systems you know I
chose the phrase atomic habits for three
reasons
so the first meaning of the word atomic
is tiny or small and that is like a you
know like an atom that's a key part of
my philosophy habits should be small and
easy to do
the second meaning of the word atomic is
the one that's often overlooked which is
the fundamental unit of a larger system
so like atoms built into molecules
molecules built into compounds and so on
and then the the third and final meaning
is the source of immense energy and
power and I think that if you understand
all three of those then you kind of get
the narrative arc of the book which is
you make changes that are small and easy
to do and then you layer them on top of
each other like units in a larger system
and if you do that then you can end up
with some really powerful and remarkable
results in the long run and it's really
the layering that on top of them the as
you just mentioned seeing the whole
framework and trying to make a variety
of these little changes rather than just
doing them haphazardly and kind of
one-off that leads to changes that
actually stick in the long run and so
having those four laws behavior change
and those different questions you can
ask yourself how can I make it obvious
how can I make it attractive how can I
make it easy how can I make it
satisfying they all kind of work
together to form a more robust framework
and increase the odds that you're
actually gonna be able to stick to the
habit in the long run I get that so can
we run through some examples for sure
making and breaking so well let's start
with with the first loss of making it
obvious so we know one of the things
that you can do here is what I call
environment design and I'll give you
some examples for both building good
habits and breaking bad ones so for good
habits you want to make the cues obvious
you want to read either remove the
distractions or add different elements
to the environment that are more likely
to catch your attention so for example
for a long time I would buy apples and
put them in the crisper in the bottom of
the fridge and then I would forget they
were there because I wouldn't see them
and then two weeks would pass and they
go bad and then I'd throw them out might
be annoyed because I'm wasting food and
wasting money and so eventually I bought
this large display bowl and I put it
right in the middle of the counter and
put the apples in the bowl and now
they're gone in like three days just
because I walked by them all the time
and they're just they're obvious or easy
to see so you can imagine a lot of
changes you can make to your kitchen
like that right like put the healthy
snacks like the nuts and the fruit and
stuff out on the counter or in ez2c
locations and then
the unhealthy stuff in the bottom of the
pantry or the back of the freezer or the
top shelf or things like that similarly
when I wanted to build a flossing habit
so for many years I would brush my teeth
consistently but I would only floss
every now and then and I realized one of
the issues was that the floss was tucked
away in a drawer in the bathroom and so
I just wouldn't see it and I wouldn't
think about it so I bought a little bowl
and I put it right next to my toothbrush
on the sink and put the floss in there
and now I brush my teeth I put the
toothbrush down and I picked the floss
up because it's right next to it and
that one little change of making it
obvious was basically all I had to do to
stick to that habit you know now I've
been doing it for years
and it's just interesting to me how
little it takes sometimes for habit to
stick so that's that's an intervention
only at the first the first stage which
is great so you know all four right like
sometimes just depends on how much
friction you're facing and how difficult
it's been for you to stick with it and
also you know how complicated the habit
is like flossing actually isn't really
that complicated of a habit so it only
needed a little bit of a nudge just
stick with that so so anyway so those
are some examples of good habits you can
also think about on the other side for
breaking a bad one so let's take for
example a lot of feel people feel like
they watch too much Netflix or spend too
much time watching television well if
you walk into pretty much any living
room where do all the couches and chairs
face like they all face the TV so what
is that room designed to get you to do
and you know I'm not saying you have to
redesign your entire home but there
there's like a spectrum of choices that
you have here you know you could take a
chair and turn it away from the TV and
have it face a coffee table with a book
on it or you could put the remote
control inside a drawer and put a book
in its place you could also put the TV
inside a wall unit or a cabinet so that
it's kind of like behind doors and
you're less likely to see it I had one
reader who she and her husband watched a
ton of sporting events and they realized
they were spending so much time on that
that they decided they just were going
to get rid of their TV and their new
metric would be if we don't care enough
about a game to drive 15 minutes down
the street and watch it the spoken
tutorial
making it invisible rather than making
it obvious but you could also employ the
so this is where I think this is where
things start to get a little more
powerful you can start to layer things
on top of each other so that's making it
invisible but you could also make it
difficult so this is the inversion of
the third law so you're trying to
increase the friction associated with
the bad habit
so you could say unplug your TV after
each use and then only plug it back in
if you can say the name of the show that
you want to watch so you're just you're
not allowed like turn it on and find
something mindlessly yeah or you could
take the batteries out of the remote
control so that it takes an extra 10
seconds to turn the TV on and maybe
that's enough time for you to be like do
I really want to watch something or am I
just kind of like mindlessly browsing
here so we need to jump there as a 1 for
social media that again another pearl of
wisdom from George who's part of the
modern wisdom project he deletes
Instagram from his phone but also turns
off the notifications when it's on his
phone so when it's on its invisible and
when it isn't it's really difficult like
if anyone's navigate to the App Store I
got downloaded that I got a read log
back in you know that's that's costly
for a while I I did something similar
where I started at each time I would
finish using the app I would log out so
then I'd have to at least type my you
know password and whatever to get back
in but then I started just deleting the
app after each use and so yeah you can
use Instagram but you do you want to
wait 60 seconds to download it and it's
funny how many times you don't actually
care enough you're like I don't actually
want to wait for this like I just wanted
to browse it mindlessly you know so just
a little bit of friction there can can
really help now if you you know
sometimes you can find ways around that
right you like oh I just didn't delete
at that time or something like that so
you can also be more strict about it and
use what scientists call a commitment
device so commitment device is a way to
kind of lock in your future behavior so
it's a choice that you make now that
makes it easier to stick with a habit in
the long time in the long run so for the
social media one I realized when I was
about a year into writing atomic habits
that like okay this is going to slow I'm
spending too much time on social I need
to make sure that I like say more focus
tearing to get this book done
so I have my assistant every Monday she
would log me out of Facebook Instagram
and Twitter
reset all the passwords I would work all
week on Friday she would give me the
passwords and then I log in over the
weekend and use social media and then on
Monday we do it all over again and so
that system right like forced my hand it
took willpower out of the equation I
couldn't login I mean I guess I could
have gone I reset the password or
something but then she would know and so
there was like this you know
accountability aspect there too and
stuff so
so anyway element commitment devices can
be a useful way to adjust that too they
also can be an example of the second law
of behavior change so the second law is
to make it attractive right the more
attractive or appealing a habit is the
more likely you are to stick with it so
let's take like a common example like
going for a run in the morning well you
might go to bed tonight and think
alright tomorrow's the day I'm gonna
wake up early I'm gonna go for a run at
6:00 a.m. so you set your alarm and then
6:00 a.m. comes around and your bed is
warm it's cold outside you're like well
maybe I'll just press news but if you
rewind the clock and go back to the
previous day and you send your friend a
text and you say hey let's meet at the
park at 6:30
well now 6 am comes around and your bed
is still warm and it's still cold
outside but if you don't get up and go
to the park
you're a jerk because you leave your
friend there all alone and so it was
actually that text that became the
commitment device for your future action
it what it did was it changed the
equation in your mind so now it's
actually more appealing more attractive
to get up out of bed than it was before
because there's an immediate cost
associated with it so you've increased
the attractiveness of the behavior so
that's sometimes people ask that like
how do you do that how do you how do you
make a habit more attractive that's one
way to do it I certainly think indeed
the attractiveness for me making a habit
more attractive especially one that's
potentially difficult having followed
the protocol that you lay out in atomic
habits that does seem sometimes to be a
one of the more difficult points to go
through like making it obvious is
because I'm gonna forget to say it how
many visuals visual cells have we got in
the body that visual sensory cells is it
like
14 million cells that sense and 10
million of them are for the visual field
yeah it's actually even a higher
percentage than that it depends on how
its analyzed and there are some
questions about the layout of it but
basically there are 11 million or so
sensory receptors in the body and 10
million of them are dedicated to vision
so like we're incredibly visually biased
we're very visual creatures it's
definitely the strong sense yeah
completely believe my mind that did that
so yeah I mean you know making it
obvious is is one but the making
attractive on that's a great example
about texting your friend that external
accountability is a big trigger yeah so
I think you're right
the making it obvious adding more cues
it tends to be a more external thing and
so I think it's easier to understand
it's easier to see whereas the craving
it's like I said it's all about the
meaning that you assigned to the cue
which means it's a very internal thing
which makes it a little bit maybe harder
to pin down or figure out like how would
I actually do something to make that
happen so the commitment device that's
one option the other thing that you
could do though is that essentially a
craving is a story that you're telling
yourself about what something means and
so if you can change that story then you
can change the craving that is
associated with that cue or you can
change the the response that you want to
take so for example let's say that you
wake up every morning and you make a
piece of toast and so when you walk into
the the kitchen you see a loaf of bread
and you interpret that cue as favorable
I'll make some toast will be enjoyable
but then you read a book that convinced
it you know some diet or nutrition book
that convinces you that grain is the
devil and so now you walk into the
kitchen and you see those same loaf of
bread but suddenly it means something
different you have a different story in
your mind about what that is now you
don't want to make a piece of toast now
you think oh this is unhealthy I should
stay away from this and so you know I'm
not advocating for a particular diet or
anything here but my point is that
education reading exploring and hearing
about new world views is a way to change
the story that you tell you
self about the same queues of the same
experiences in your life and if you
change the story
then you've effectively changed the
craving and what is attractive and what
isn't attractive so reading widely can
actually be a way to change the cravings
that you have associated with particular
habits it can be tough because just
readings about something once might not
change like a lifetime of evidence and
experience for that and this is also it
comes back a little bit to something I
talked about early in the book which I
call identity based habits and it's this
idea that every action is like a vote
for the kind of person that you want to
become and so if you if you want to
change the story that you're telling
yourself about a particular cue if you
want to change the craving that you have
then what you need to do is you need to
provide evidence of that news story
evidence of that new identity and so you
can do it in a small way and start
casting votes for that identity start
building up evidence and proof of this
new story and then eventually if you get
enough proof you'll start to believe it
so for example if your current story is
oh I always give up whenever I start a
workout routine or I never stick with
anything or whatever
well now you can focus on like just
doing one push up a day so it does it
it's not enough to transform your body
it's not gonna get you the results that
you want of you know losing a bunch of
weight on the scale or something but it
does cast a vote for being the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts it does
reinforce this new story of I am a
healthy person I'm the type of person
who's consistent or I'm type of person
who works out every day and in the
beginning I think that counts for a lot
because you're just trying to build up
evidence of this new story that you're
telling yourself this new identity that
you're trying to build and so I think in
the long run that's another way to
change your craving and change whether
habit is attractive to you or not and
then the final thing I'll say on that is
that your social environment you can be
a big influence on what habits are
attractive or which are unattractive you
know like you have eaten pork all your
life and then you join a new religion
where isn't allowed and so now pork is
very unattractive
in comparison to what it was in the past
because eating it would get you
ostracized from the group and you lose
your friends and so on and so the social
reinforcement there is like a very
strong driver of whether that habit
sticks or not and the same thing is true
on you know a much more everyday scale
so like let's say you move into a new
neighborhood and you walk outside on
Tuesday night and you see that all your
neighbors have their recycling bins out
and you think oh we need to sign up for
recycling that's what people like us do
in this neighborhood and you stick with
that habit of recycling every week for
twenty years largely because it's
socially reinforced because the
expectation to act that way from your
neighbors and so on and so that suddenly
makes the habit of recycling much more
attractive to stick with because it
means it's a signal that you belong to
the group or that you get it that you
that you're part of the community so I
guess just combining all that commitment
devices can be a short-term way to
change the attractiveness of a habit and
identity and social reinforcement or
more long-term ways to kind of shift
which habits are attractive in the long
run I understand so we're moving on to
response now we've got cue we've got the
craving and now we're on to the response
so you know this is mostly about making
your habits easy convenient simple to do
making them the path of least resistance
and you know there are a variety of
things you do here but the one that I
usually start with recommending is what
I call the 2-minute rule
so you basically take whatever habit
you're trying to build and you scale it
down to something it takes two minutes
or less to do so you're just making it
very simple so read forty books a year
becomes read one page or do yoga four
days a week becomes take out my yoga mat
and sometimes people like resist that
you know they're like well I know the
real thing I want to do is actually do
the workout like I'm not just looking to
take my yoga mat out every day and so
they kind of feel like it's this mental
trick but if you feel that way then I
would encourage you just to limit
yourself to like the first two minutes
or three minutes I had a reader actually
who he ended up losing over a hundred
pounds and one of the first things they
did was he went to the gym but he wasn't
allowed to stay for longer than 5 min
so he would get in his car drive to the
gym get out do half an exercise he'd
back in the car drive home and it sounds
silly to people at first right it sounds
ridiculous it's like this is not gonna
be the thing that gets this guy in shape
but what you realize is that he was
mastering the art of showing up he was
becoming the type of person that went to
the gym four days a week even if it was
only for five minutes and I think that
that's like a deeper truth about how
habits work which is that a habit must
be established before it can be improved
you know like you need to make it the
standard in your life before you worry
about optimizing and expanding and
upgrading from there and so often we're
focused on finding like the perfect diet
plan or the ideal workout program or the
best business idea we get so caught up
in like doing it perfectly from the
start that we don't give ourselves
permission to show up in a small way and
I think it mostly starts with that like
allow yourself to show up and be there
making your new normal even if it's only
for two minutes and then you can upgrade
and expand afterward it's a common
citation from trainers that say the best
workout program is one that you stick to
and the same thing for meditation and
I'm struggling day by day to develop a
more sophisticated reading habit so for
me I did exactly that although this was
before I read atomic habits at the start
of last rails I look just five minutes
after my morning routine which is quite
kind of hermetic as it is so it was good
I'll take a look I'm struggling to
concentrate I'm used to a high degree of
stimulus from electronic devices looking
at a piece of paper makes me feel
agitated physically because there's not
enough there's no enough stimulus going
on just just read like five minutes
after you finish your meditation like
the books there it's next to you it's
obvious it's easy because I can reach
for it etc etc and that's now built up
to the point where the flight over I'm
currently in San Bernadino in California
and the flight over from London to LA
which is ten and a half hours and I just
read the whole time that's one year on
but so you know I mean the plane is a
very specific example in that there is
like fuck-all Elsie
you can do on a plane really unless you
want to watch like Mission Impossible 4
over and over again but sure
so yes we've got the cue craving
response we've got the response for good
habits how about for bad well so this is
mostly about increasing friction so the
harder it is to do the action the less
likely you are to do it so if you find
yourself biting your nails then you
could like wrap bandages around your
finger tips or you could wear oven mitts
which I've heard about people doing
things like that right it's now so hard
to do it right yeah it's not so hard to
do it that you can now I bring that
example up because I think it
illustrates the fact like well that
would be ridiculous right to wear oven
mitts all day long so sometimes it's
more effective to focus on other areas
like other the three other steps rather
than write you and you'll see this for
most habits that they're probably one or
two areas of intervention that are like
the low-hanging fruit and you should
probably start there but anyway so you
could increase friction that way you can
also imagine like say you're trying to
quit smoking well if there's pack of
cigarettes on the table ten feet from
you that's much harder to resist then if
the closest pack of cigarettes is like
15 miles away down the road at like the
gas station right so you want some
friction there you can also do you know
I mentioned some of the eating examples
earlier about like putting fruit on the
counter and you know nuts in an obvious
place things like that there's a story
from BJ Fogg who's a professor at
Stanford and he also writes about habits
and he said he enjoyed eating popcorn
he liked eating it he just didn't want
to eat as much of it and so he took it
out of his pantry walked down the
hallway went to the garage and put it on
the highest shelf in the garage now if
he really wants it he can just go out
and get it something him takes 60
seconds but if he's designing for his
lazy decision for his default action
like what is he gonna do when he was
exhausted and tired after a long day at
work he's not gonna go out and get it
and that really kind of captures the
essence of this idea of like making it
difficult you want to put more steps
between you and the bad behaviors and
fewer steps between you and the good
ones and if you're operating and working
an environment that's like that no
single choice is going to transform your
habits but when you put them all
together imagine how much easier would
be to make the right choice if you have
like thirty of those little decisions
that are kind of nudging you in the
right direction so it's mostly about
increasing the number of steps are
increasing the friction of the action
don't you and finally the reward how are
we working on that well so the basic
idea here is that the reason habits
stick is because the ending of the habit
is satisfying and you can sort of divide
this on a timeline so there's sort of an
immediate outcome and an ultimate
outcome an instant gratification and a
delayed gratification associated with
habits now with bad habits the immediate
outcome is often favorable and this is
one of the key reasons why we stick with
them you know it's like what is the
immediate outcome of eating a doughnut
well that's great it's sweet but sugary
it tastes good it's only the ultimate
outcome if you keep eating donuts for
six months or a year or two years that's
unfavorable and with good habits it's
often the reverse right like what's the
immediate outcome of going to the gym
for a week it's kind of unfavorable your
body's probably sore you're you haven't
really changed at all you look the same
in the mirror the scale is basically the
same so you don't have a whole lot to
show for it it's only once you've stuck
with that habit for six months or a year
or two years that you start to get the
changes in your body that you were
hoping for so with good habits the
immediate outcome is often unfavorable
or has some kind of cost and the
ultimate outcome is where the rewards
actually lie and I mean you can just
summarize this by saying the cost of
your good habits is in the present the
cost of your bad habits is in the future
and so much of the battle of building
good habits and breaking bad ones is
figuring out ways to pull a little bit
of that reward in to the present moment
for good habits so that you have a
reason to stick with it while you're
kind of working through this like valley
of death where you're waiting so just to
accumulate and four bad habits pulling
some of the consequences from the future
into the present moment so you feel a
little bit of that pain right now
so you have a reason to avoid it so in
the case of like one example for a good
habit let's say let's say that you're
trying to send sales
emails for you know prospecting emails
for your business or you are meditating
for 10 minutes a day or you're gonna
write one page a day or a thousand words
a day and whenever you do that habit you
have a jar of marbles in front of you
and that jar of marbles has like 90 blue
marbles and 10 red ones for example and
each time that you do the habit you pull
a marble out of the jar and if you pull
out one of the 90 then nothing happens
just like pat on the back good job you
do what you're supposed to but if you
pull out one of the ten then you get
some kind of reward that's exciting to
you maybe it's a piece of chocolate
maybe it take a bubble bath maybe get to
go for a walk outside maybe get to watch
an hour of Netflix for whatever you want
whatever it is that's interesting to you
but we've done is you've introduced some
element of surprise and like instant
reward into that habit so now you have a
reason to feel good about it in the
moment you you wrote for you wrote your
thousand words and your book still isn't
finished but you got to pull out one of
the fun marbles and so you get to watch
Netflix for an hour so there's a little
bit of an immediate reward there that's
a angle with the ultimate thing that
you're working toward and then the key
the caveat that I want to add to this is
that you want to choose a form of
reinforcement a form of reward that
aligns with your desired identity right
so like some people will go to the gym
and then reward themselves with like a
cup of ice cream and it's like well
you're casting one vote for a healthy
person and one vote for an unhealthy one
so it's sort of like a wash you know so
you want instead maybe you could say you
get to have a bubble bath which both
going to the gym and taking a bubble
bath are a vote for taking care of your
body and so it's kind of like
reinforcing the same identity but even
at a minimum I think you know doesn't
they don't always have to align
perfectly but at a minimum it shouldn't
conflict with your desired identity so
anyway that's a that's an example of how
to like make it satisfying in the moment
and try to overcome that misalignment of
the immediate and ultimate outcome of
your habits and how about the bots so
this is mostly about adding some kind of
consequence to the behavior one good
examples what we talked about earlier
about the idea of texting your friend to
go meet
to run at the park so previously
sleeping in didn't have any kind of
consequence you could press snooze and
it wasn't a big deal but now suddenly
you press snooze and your bad friend and
so there's some immediate outcome that's
changed the equation a little bit so
this this also shows you I mentioned
very early on when we talked about the
four stages about the the reward
satisfies the craving that came before
the action so the second stage in the
fourth stage are kind of tied to each
other the second stage is your
anticipation of the outcome and the
fourth stage is the realization of that
outcome and so for that reason the
strategies that in that make habits more
attractive also simultaneously make it
more satisfying or make the if you skip
the habit they make it unsatisfying so
there they kind of like they work with
each other so texting your friend not
only makes it more attractive to get up
it makes it unsatisfying or adds a
consequence to sleeping in so they kind
of like work with each other there I
totally get it James I can't sing
appraises about about atomic habit so
genuinely can't we have created the
[ __ ] duo which is deep work by
Cal Newport and that's great well Cal is
Cal does great work so I'm happy to be
in company with them that's very good I
challenge anyone to read those two books
and not come out of it as a complete
[ __ ] but um today's been
fantastic anyone who is interested I
will link your website in the show notes
below am i right in thinking you've
nearly got half a million newsletter
subscribers now yeah it's been crazy but
but it's great and really happy and
grateful to have that many readers and
I'll just do my best to keep sharing
useful ideas there how does it how does
it feel to have half a million people
like you you press a button and when
that button gets pressed that half a
million people see something yeah I try
not to think about it because when I
just get in my head too much and you
start spiraling into perfectionism and
worrying about it not being good enough
but but on my good days I feel really
grateful for it and it's just it's cool
you know like I I write ideas because I
hope that they make the world a little
bit of a better place or make some small
impact in my little corner of the
universe and so
to have people reading and enjoying and
finding it useful and using them in
their daily lives like that's what it's
all about so so yeah I'm really happy
and grateful for it
fantastic genuinely do you think that
you are making making a really big
impact so thank you so much for your
time I really appreciate it yeah you bet
thanks for having me on
good talk thank you
[Music]